all right welcome back this is exciting
there are two new musicals here in Las
Vegas two totally different ends of the
spectrum too you get a little bit of
everything there at the V theater so I
think uh Planet Hollywood you know
Miracle Mile Musical and a musical about
Star Wars right we're kind of all over
here so um producer and director Tom
dangora hi thank you for joining us and
then in the green um what do we have
there oh okay I got the baby Yoda for a
holiday sweater on this morning and
Kristen Alderson thank you the face of
one of the shows as well so you guys
these are
two completely different shows yes how
does this come about the same world
though okay so musical is kind of like
SNL the musical right uh written by This
brilliant guy named rickrome directed by
Mark Waldrop produced by me starring
these guys it's all the News That's 50
spoof and a musical about Star Wars is
just that it's a musical about Star Wars
in about 70 minutes we pack in every
single thing in the Canon from the Star
Wars holiday special to A New Hope to
the prequels to the new stuff on Netflix
to baby Yoda you'll get a little touch
of everything even baby Yoda okay um
yeah that's incredible and a person who
goes to the show is going to see both
shows you can they they're back to back
at the V theater um every day on Monday
at 4 30 uh because Star Wars is family
friendly and then musicals that's six
you know that's a so we get a little
more into our Eve maybe a little more
yeah okay
so tell me you're watching eight news
now in the morning to get some of your
content there for the oh yeah
while watching you yeah yeah yeah John
and I are in trouble about that so okay
so we're at the V Theater which is
wonderful great location what are we
what are we looking at as far as ticket
prices for families oh you I think if
you're going there's deals everywhere if
you go on vegas.com I think they range
from like 30 to 110. awesome if you want
that elegant front row okay and there is
shows folks on Christmas Eve and
Christmas day so if you're looking for
something fun to do
um now Kristen you are an Emmy
award-winning opera star so welcome to
Las Vegas how fun to have you on our you
know in the mix oh I I'm loving Las
Vegas especially this weather as you see
the other weather that's going on we're
lucky wow um so very happy to be here uh
yes doing daytime television is very
different from doing live live stage
where you're doing impressions I'm doing
Kim Kardashian Britney Spears and Celine
Dion on in musical the musical so it's
very funny and very uh exciting that's
correct yeah those are three fun people
to kind of parody oh yeah all people
that I love like I'm a huge Britney
Spears and Celine Dion fan so it's all
you know poking fun of them with love
that's awesome and Taylor I know you you
helped write what's it like doing all
this so how do you do it all it's a
whirlwind but it's so much fun you know
I've known Tom for years and I first uh
was doing musical the musical with Tom
in New York City
um and from that is how Star Wars also
came about
um and so in the world we kind of live
in like like we were hinting it earlier
both two different shows but kind of the
same skill set so you know like in
musical I'll be doing Matthew
McConaughey and I'll be doing that and
I'll be talking like this and I'll be
doing my thing and chilling we're having
a good time on a good day Las Vegas
Star Wars and then I do the Alec
Guinness impression of the old Obi-Wan
be like you don't want to watch good day
you want to watch Good morning in Las
Vegas
yeah yeah yeah so we're always so those
skill sets work and it's just it's just
been a lot of fun to you know make a
show with with one of your dear friends
another one of our friends Scott Foster
wrote it with us and then the compo the
this amazing composer named Billy risi
we met and brought in and we all wrote
it together and it was so much fun so
much talent I wish we had more time to
talk to you guys but we are going to see
a little snippet of one of the shows
coming up so stick around uh the the
Jennifer Coolidge will be performing for
us guys thanks for waking
musical the musical.com a musical about
star wars.com you've got all the info
there get after it and uh I'm gonna send